what is happening there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg and John here to watch
The Witcher season three episode two today
as we wrap up Henry cavill's last season
of part one of his last season John how
are you I am Cav filled with anticipation
filled anyway how are you better uh ladies and
gentlemen if you didn't catch our episode one
reaction that is up here on the channel right now
so please go ahead toss a coin to the like button
and also subscribe click the notification Bell get
notified when our reaction for the next episode is
up on this channel as always full length retro
watch along is resync with your own copy of The
Witcher available for our super sexy Rejects at
our patreon page cover several things exclusively
over there with reaction highlights and watch
Longs included I want to say thank you to everyone
who's been joining our page uh beginning so many
pledges so far and uh this means a lot it means it
means it's definitely a positive extension of
the real rejects let's get into action people
thank you
foreign [Music] yes what's a mage doing all the
way out here she should be focusing on keeping the
Royal peace everyone noticed her eyes looking like
that though she can Idol around me tonight we keep
their beauty by bathing in human blood every night
huh no no no that's hearsay yeah you just have to
go through a magical ordeal to get the beauty good
speed Miss it was just wishing you a safe journey
oh damn never mind not a premonition flashback
she was kicked in head by a horse way to keep
it together sir you're gonna be fine on this
fugitive Adventure I can't control my vision
you can control me stop calling me like I'm a
muelling brat I saw his death and I need
to go back there oh it was a premonition
everybody it's okay A little bit of both because
there was definitely like old rants in there and
yeah I promise girls to keep you safe we need
something untraceable maybe change her look
we're going shopping we're going shopping or is
he ask here to do the Montage Music you don't
have any magic that can just slightly alter your
appearance yeah you would think how much could
their information possibly cost to find her
something Siri a lot and why do we need that
oh cool special Witcher door you know I
had that safety device replaced just now
next time making that point
now roll those opening credits
now this will help get you what you deserve look
at that balance you haven't fixed the balance no
[__] you told me to she the one related
to yeah oh God one day I'll learn his name
[Laughter]
jeez drink
you want the White Flame to be
poisoned kind of well now drink
I said drink it's a good thing you're drunk
would hurt a lot more he is true he threatened
to get a friend of mine sorcerer's
rejects too often train as killers
Sorcerers rejects that sounds cool that's
when we're covering stuff like this yeah
any amount of coin I'm afraid that information
will cost you a bit more geralt oh my God she
knows how much it is yeah let's try a wager I
shot her my back you shall throw this at my head
should you miss you will give me the
information that I want on credit of
course you'll still be able to catch it
though he didn't stipulate the rules yeah
you didn't even Flinch why would I flinch
I heard you having to mess having someone
on a leash whose leash we don't know we
do know where this sorcerer is doing his
dirty business there is a castle called volpan
it's near the old Scarlet how are my mind yes
great this time of year do you give
our best to the Elder blood princess
it's time to throw that star at her head they
know all you have a client looking for her
damn it you want to save her you need to find
another girl an orphan of War perhaps someone
has to die so someone else can live maybe you
should die series hair I will not pay for what
I love by having contempt for myself bars Henry
Cavill framed so well I know cameras eats them up
I don't want to put you in Harm's Way Again
that's why I have to go to volpan I'll come
find you when Ryan's is dead well he'll find
me once you are this guy is not gonna kill him
Carol's like you know it's not gonna happen well
welcome home writing is rewriting
handmaiden and I are in need of one
foreign
no one counts have a vision
[Music]
oh they open I won't be looking
oh run right you have no idea
whoa whoa
laughs that is one of huvenago's men you don't
want to end up decapitated I suggest you run
too give a weight I think there was a portal
open Shoulda let her come through the portal
mountainizing chaos
internet the alma mater we're wondering why the
kings are losing faith and it was because we knew
the elves were a problem and we did nothing
about it returns risk the full test court and
let's get this rough patch smooth loath as I
am to admitted if you were to return to court
I am best placed here with you helping these girls
learn what they're capable of but I can't help but
wonder if it's really about them of course not
you are a bad teacher Tris tell me about the L
ately
myself in different ways
what did you do it's foreplay I cannot tell
I think this is a role play it's been useful
sadists you almost give me perspective Clarity or
is this like their therapy milfguard's not
the only ones who know it's ripe for the
for the taking and if radovid could
be useful to us two retain you
yeah those two detectives carteringer and Fenn
they know who riens is working for I appreciate
the information what I really want is a song the
audience wants a song every season He Is Us ah
now that was foreplay this season sucks give me
what I want Netflix I know we'll get
a song Eventually guys I'm just joking
give me the noise
say we needed to avoid unwanted attention
you know all those lessons I should have
thought to you that sometimes discretion is
more important than Valor no I don't know I
had to do work I chose to interfere dominicusan
Argo will send his cousin Leo bonhardt here to
recuperate his losses with money with blood
and then we're gonna get more action scenes
you saved one and the consequences likely
damned a hundred others in exchange what
is the point in me seeing the future
if I can't do anything to change it
looks cool that is a really great question yeah
why would you understand you see what she wants
you make it happen how would you know what
it's like to fight for control of your life
if you'd seen my backstory man my ugly one
we're taking a detour why do you call me that
because I promised I'd be sincere with you from
here forward I want to show you who I really am
he's a hunchback oh goodness
oh sword man Tahir gets a great return ah come
on here you'll pay for this Nils Guardian scum
whoa some Evil Dead [__]
right there get up old friend
Francesca spells are nonsense about prophecies
so we don't die from hunger and Frost and all
you point these are supposed to be superstitious
who you can't pointy apparently the princess is
the savior of Alvin Klein you've considered
my proposal to take charge of the elves hi
you were a man's top General now I
sent you the raid Caravans on the
ass end of the battle lines why the hell
is he wasting God's giving Talent like
yours it's nice to see Robbie Amell like
someone yeah if I agree to your proposal
what does overthrower Francesca say about
my loyalty you will help him take the north
not Francesca he earned my loyalty I see you and
yours damn I want these two to be biting ship them
or that even better you're not a problem with
you Majors well you're too bloody serious
man this is the best kind of jail though oh [__]
keep getting them drunk until they're poisoned
I'm assume much I just skate once they sent the
dogs oh [__] the emperor only absorbs you that's
your dad that's it she can figure deaths probably
yeah stop her heartbeat we got another one
put them in the bag you're nice to help me
throw him out Jesus me keep your words on
ice I'm listening they say keep on playing ice
but I have no desire songs are good man [Music]
falsetto the greatest songs are made
of unspoken Words of Love preach with you I have
enough with you I am enough yes so in love with
our Barton he loves him he's so bored with life
but he feels when he asked gear sings [Music]
not how he sings the emotion so well
it's been too long yaskir I
always wondered what it was
that made your song so resistible now I understand
come on you see people for what they are not
what they pretend to be my God kiss come on
I don't know yet I'm determined
to figure it out there's like two
vampires I will dig around about this
Rihanna's character and his cohorts
yeah they have they're giving such and rice
right now I really like this guy a lot yeah
sneaking mission
holy that was cool wow
[Music]
that is cool God that's like
a Freddy Krueger nightmare
squelching intensifies are you all right oh
no are there any more like you here so many
more growing decoys what's his name Bria
always a sauce
oh
absolutely the centipede
oh no
all right
whatever I like this design a lot yeah
whoa jeez oh
it's sweet
it's such a nightmare
whoa It's like a Parry with so
many different arms yeah [Music]
I love a good over the shoulders that was
just geralt button mashing the whole time
wow
rest in peace nobody checks any kind of bag
in this place I don't even check a pulse nope
he seems to think there's old farts
Cod Runner and fan might have some
info about re-ents perhaps I need
to pay those old farts a visit too
I said to him I'll give you a head start but
you argue an arrow in the bum now I yell go he
scuttles off like a wounded deer and then I shot
oh no no no no no no no no no no no no no no no
it's really hard it was gonna
kill something oh this guy damn
Philippa seems to think that you might
have more width than meets the eye
The Hope plays a fool yeah excuse me it
has no secrets from me and you do know
about his meeting last night with MILF God
oh he's having fun sowing the seeds of Chaos
nothing why am I even asking you're going dead
did they ever leave this room I don't think they
can you know who I mean the witch was here I
could still smell the stench did you tell him
we didn't mention anything about your employer
what do you know about his plans if you harm them
oh you gotta be [__] me
nope it's become everything
as long as a cat didn't die I'm okay
I sympathize with him now I'm rooting
for him we need to get the northern Kings
to listen to us and work together and the
last thing they want to see is the woman
who set their execution party in place
but you love her God knows you won't fond of her
that's only because we have too much in common
the overwhelming name to win an argument the
love for you yeah that was a little different
the end's more like my daughter
if yennefer can let go of the past
so can I and everybody else ah I've seen
Vanderpump Rules grudges will be held
how much of a pig how much for this piece
don't you dare take your eyes off me
I forgot how heartbreaking it was watching that
episode yeah thank you I once chose to interfere
I set a prisoner free and in doing so I set
the entire knowledge against the Brotherhood
bodies hanging at the tavern your
fault it's not enough to possess chaos
we must learn to control it that is the
essence of power how we will move mountains
South hello you're out of that
place now you're safe I knew you
and how would you know that a vision who are you
don't be silly girl you know who I
am I'm Siri why did you say that name
so yeah I was weird obviously she's supposed to
look like Siri the whole time though I was sitting
there going like is that the actress's sister
or something like the actress who plays Siri
Allen or whatever oh interesting timelines
are only gonna get more confusing yeah
yeah all right well I like that more than last
episode yeah I did too looked at a lot more in the
last episode for sure yeah I was back to more of
what I wanted it to be watch our opinions become
even more out of the general public I know it
was like people thought the first one was the
best I don't know what this means for me yeah
yeah I really like this one a lot um you you
start start John start yes sir uh no yeah this
breathed like this season thus far has certainly
a more modern sensibility about its dialogue but
I thought this episode in terms of pace in terms
of what we focused on in terms of the uh momentum
with which we're developing things felt a little
more natural a little more breathable and it felt
a little bit more like inhabiting you know this
fantastic goal you know a medievalesque world
in a more I don't know sensory kind of way like
like the last episode was like oh we're hopping
around we're doing a bunch of stuff and it feels
like a Hollywood movie sort of whereas this was
like okay I can feel the scope and the breadth of
the map and and all these different places that
we're in and I think breaking the characters
up again as much as it is like fun to have them
together uh you know I think it certainly helps
just the spatial and the temporal geography of the
show um so yeah I mean like I enjoyed especially
I mean it's always fun to watch girl kick ass
but I especially enjoyed the the kind of back
and forth between Siri and yennefer and the ways
that you know is allowed to I feel like in the
previous episode again we were talking about like
ah it doesn't seem like these moments are allowed
to be like earned by the process of really
living in them whereas here yeah I I could
really see Siri's perspective of like I've got
these abilities I want to intervene because that
is what's right and then yeah I thought that was
a great time for Jennifer to kind of bring back
that bit of context both of where she came from
because obviously Siri views her as somebody who
just has power already uh innately and yeah then
tying that back around to the more not the present
but the more recent past with everything with her
and kahir and everything yeah I just thought that
yeah like it it felt like it was calling
upon its Tome of details and it's you know
scope of world in a way that felt yeah more
akin to what I've been enjoying thus far about
the first couple of seasons um these are all great
thoughts John thanks happy to hear that thank you
oh it's always good to get uh the the couple back
prince's name right yeah okay all right that's the
character yeah I'm really liking a lot Prince rad
David I mean I like the inclusion right now of red
vid raid ratavid and um Gallatin uh Robia Mel's
Elf character yes the realistic Alpha the one who
doesn't succumb to folk tales fairy tales and all
that [__] yeah it's about science and climate
change you know [Laughter] in Congo I like it I
know I like his presence a lot he's a really cool
elf and uh yeah he's a really he's really fun to
watch and so far I mean a lot of it is still we're
still in very much setup stages so mainly what
I just want to talk about is the main takeaways
of things as I feel like uh sure we can like sort
of hop around every little thing we checked in on
um but I thought every character we checked in on
I enjoyed every scene that we got this time around
yeah uh right down to even the goddamn names on
this show are just not my thing what is the guy
who's also at House of the Dragon who's getting
whipped dixtra I like what they're doing with him
because he was just stoic um you know spy before
and now he's got like a real personality and you
really see some Bare Bones Humanity to him join
that the rienne's character sure makes me like
him uh dislike him as a villain when we're
trying to say dislike him in the right way as
a villain by who he killed in this episode a tad
bit more sure um Stills like the the mystery the
every season sort of built around some type
of mystery in some capacity and right now
that mystery is not like very strong but the
immediate moment of watching the show has been
very enjoyable like the monster that we got this
time you gotta have an action scene with geralt
every episode I suppose in the monster that he
fought was a really neat design I liked how those
like heads were totally like science fiction kind
of monster heads were Tethered to this creature it
kind of reminds me of like when you fight like a
multiple head dragon in a way well yeah and it's
like the perfect distraction because it's like the
heads are there to throw you off and to like make
you doubt and the body is just gonna collaborate
you yeah such a great design screaming the pain
of the centipede bodies it was really cool it was
a really cool design and I I am enjoying the uh
they they said it about a different character
here but it is a word that is applied um aptly
for Siri as well impetuous the impetuous side
of Siri because yes you can make some decisions
that go but then you're like but it makes sense
why you're doing that you know I at least you're
doing it for just causes just purposes and we're
really building something right we're building two
windows yeah I mean they teased that at the end
of last season yeah because right now it is the
hunt for Syria that's the that's the main focus
here and I like how they're trying to go to oh my
God help me out John uh teratuza is trying to go
to aratuza yeah for that's that's where you know
um Jennifer feels like that is the safety spot
for it but we know there's also danger looming
for Siri there like no matter where she goes it
is funny enough the prince in last episode saying
that this is the least bad spot for her is kind of
like the only decisions that yeah Siri is sort of
left with yeah you know um and I like that geralt
is a lot more soft when speaking with certain
characters here write down his relationship with
the askier uh but I feel like there's a chance of
things being frayed when he finds out what yaskir
has really been up to when he asked you've really
been doing but the the bond that the prince has
with the asker I think is a really interesting
one there's definitely some homo erotic thing
going on over there oh yeah and I hope it does
pan out in that direction that would be a lot
of fun to watch you could see it on you ask
your side that he's more than likely a bisexual
so I would be down for it um so right down to the
prince as well sure yeah sure let it happening
I don't know what their label is all right I'm
just saying they probably swing both ways uh
let it yes go for it let it happen yeah and
yes the witches will rise certainly
and uh I mean that seems like all the
big stuff I mean you know there's
you know you got Tris back there
eritus that having her conflicts we saw
vilga Fords for a second he's cool uh
uh we got to see a dwarf lady make a sword yeah
yeah what's that guy's name dwarf guy Witcher
is that Zoltan all right I thought it was
something else there you go yarp so maybe that is
one of his distant relations I like the the woman
who plays uh by the IMDb I'm going with Philippa
uh who is who's like a lot with Dexter this
season like I feel like her inclusion has helped
I mean she's an interesting character she's a good
actor and also now Deeks was more interesting as
a byproduct of that which is nice and uh and
yeah it was nice to get geralt just like off
on his own doing a doing a hunt and it makes me
wonder if maybe again not knowing the source of
material if they're gonna mess with time where
we are in the timeline again because I mean they
could easily go girl it went off but also he's
in the past or also this is like a prior thing
or something I don't know it feels of the
present but also that whole thing with like
I'm Siri feels like it could be some weird
I don't know intermingling of points in time
or it's the Multiverse or it's the Multiverse
I hope this gets a Multiverse not enough
multiverses these days and then season five
we'll have Liam Hemsworth and Henry Cavill
yes oh perfect and then we can get Chris
Hemsworth to play to play geralt as well
and Ben Affleck can play geralt I can see
all them playing different versions of camera
he does move just the way he moves though
I don't know there's something about Henry
County I I always find myself remembering
and appreciating in this show in particular
because in Superman it like it's kind of easy
to overlook in some ways because there's so
many effects but here I'm like yeah man it seems
like he really gets in there with the stunts and
and you know and the choreography and they do a
lot to make it apparent that it's him yeah or or
if not that's a great Stitch job on the CG face
but I have no idea what to make of that ending
me neither it's really confusing sure
reincarnation thingy yeah hop in between
I mean obviously with Siri being able to hop
between the past and the future some type of
mine 's plant yeah thingy cloning facility that's
it it's actually there will be a Twist it's the
present day and series just got a stage of the
art cloning facility this is growing serious Nokes
I don't know I don't know the show is designed
to be binged so sure good episode I'll say this
one was a solid installment I know we don't talk
for I'm not talking for too long this time around
we're trying to just get through the these five
yeah have a longer discussion by the time we wrap
up for the fifth episode but so far um I this
was a uh more of an upswing for for myself like
I marked improvement wasn't as much in love with
the first episode because it seems like everyone
in our comment box really out of touch here
this will be good this is our Redemption Journey
Through the watch that be like I don't know after
first episode went down but yeah this was this is
definitely better to me and um oh yeah yeah okay
there's a thing I need Clarity on uh oh yeah ask
your song short but again there's something very
effective about every one of his songs no matter
what they are there's something very effective
about them I want the whole album of the ask
yours Tunes I do too the the the thing with the
the little boy who was saved and they said who
was coming after him yes what the hell's uh who
what I was like they clarified uh how that thing
was set up with the ask gear at the end of season
two and I was like oh yeah yeah sorry it's been a
while since I've seen the show oh there's a lot of
a lot of room every every season requires a full
rewatch or two no it really does that was that
was something I was thinking of about and then
and then I'll yeah like it seemed like the part
of the way they're writing this season is sort of
acknowledging that like uh you might not have just
watched this because it's been a long time yeah
like you know obviously you want all that fresh in
your mind uh in the moment I mean I I was mostly
latched onto that just as an illustration of
yennefer's point but yeah I mean if that hearkens
back to to the end of season two if he's involved
with that bigger picture then that's a that's a
wrinkle I'm gonna have to refresh myself on yeah
I don't remember yeah that's kind of confusing no
yeah I thought it was just like ah you know you
don't you didn't just freeze some random kid like
ah now they're gonna be like you know officials
are gonna hear about this and send people yeah
um but I I also like getting a reminder of
where Jennifer's come from and how she would
be the perfect proponent to guiding Siri yeah
or how far she's come that way I mean that was
such a vivid part of her performance and I really
loved that version like as much as like of course
you want her to you know be in her full like
range of power and capability like there was
just something very and physically hot yeah of
course gotta be hot that's the thing is like you
know I would never sacrifice the hotness but the
drama almost worth it um and yeah it's like you
don't get any new newly shot scenes that way but
I do like having it be sort of a reminder because
it was such a vivid and such a unique thing
about that first season and so I feel like
I don't know she doesn't need that to be
interesting but I do feel like it's a it's
a distinct part of the character
that is worth not losing yeah yeah
alrighty well episode two down three more to
go Hells yeah I'm excited benjamal right now
this minute I'm okay let's read a book in an
hour all right but before we head out let's do it
Lord Brandon of house Benzie my dude listen
I want to join your house all right what's
your sigil you know I feel like we should
figure it out right here right now uh yes
I think it should be the three fingers
and a hand and a finger going through
yeah that's what it is yeah it's a symbol
of synergy it's a symbol of you know it's
it's things are okay and that's where
we're going is towards worth okay okay
the Brandon Benzie house
together they form kind of like a six and a
nine upside down sure yeah yeah yeah you put
the two humps you put the one hump in between the
other hump and the other hump yeah it's like it's
like a 69 for two perfect butt cheeks totally yeah
yeah two two B's for two butts for for so there's
many different schedules we just went through all
three seasons oh yeah yeah and season one and then
he was like a six and a nine and it's
season three is like two bees touching
each other like two butts yeah but it's
not actually sexual YouTube no no no yeah
and then the third and then the final one
is like it's it's it's kind of like the 69
formation but you're just hugging each other's
tummies yeah yeah totally that's the BB way
and these are all deciduals of all the different
episodes of your season so uh you know we'll smelt
them in pewter and we'll send them to you as a
special token of our gratitude but Brandon Benzie
would be honored to uh you know to fly your flag
at my house and uh yeah stay pledged you know toss
that coin bag we won't count it and we'll see you
next month love you buddy love you buddy [Music]